[Music]
thank you
welcome to the climate show with me Tom
Heap and this week we're all about
nature and we're in a little bit of wild
bedfordshire yeah there is some
Wilderness in this County and the reason
we're focusing on nature is because of a
big meeting that's happening in Canada
Montreal in fact and the United Nations
Secretary General gave this Gathering a
really big build up
Humanity has become a weapon of mass
extinction
we are treating nature like a toilet and
ultimately we are committing suicide by
proxy that Summit is a gathering of
governments from around the world trying
to agree ways to stop the loss of nature
across the planet and preferably begin
to restore it as well some very very
ambitious targets we'll hear about them
later but this isn't just about what
happens in the Amazon or in the savannah
It Matters To Nature here in the UK and
later on in the program we'll hear from
two managers here in bedfordshire with
different views on how that should
happen but we will be taking a step away
from our Shores to talk to someone who's
had some great success in restoring
nature he's a man that's really really
passionate about frogs and will also be
taking a step back in time nature of
course has been thriving on this planet
much longer than we have as humans and
we'll be revealing a really ancient
ecosystem
or to get the lowdown on what this
United Nations meeting is all about I'm
joined by someone from Sky news's own
ecosystem science correspondent Thomas
Moore with me here in the undergrowth
Thomas what is happening in Montreal so
this is a meeting being held by the
United Nations pulling everybody
together trying to come up with a
blueprint for reversing this decline of
nature by 2030. now at the moment the
text runs to thousands of words and it's
full of brackets about 790 of them
containing phrases that are
controversial stuff that needs to be
agreed by people within the room and
that's really hard I gather this
headline aim is to get 30 percent of the
land and see is it into some kind of
natural state by 2030 yes and you know
it's a tiny proportion is currently
properly protected where nature can run
right those controversial that's
controversy over that too because there
are some who say that even the protected
areas aren't properly protected that
they're really just lines on a map and
and that the nature still is under
pressure from even fishing in areas
which are supposed to be protected and
does this involve governments making
commitments to say we say we will
protect this amount of sea or this
amount of land and having to show how
they're going to do it yes so there's
going to be some verification this time
previous attempts to reach an agreement
have failed but this time we've got much
more technology so you can you can track
shipments you can track the where crops
are coming from so you will know through
satellites whether there is an element
of deforestation that has resulted in
for example palm oil ending up in
products back on the supermarkets here
you make a really good point there we've
now got this eye in the sky looking down
because I've seen some of those maps of
the globe that show kind of every single
ship so you can see illegal fishing you
can see different colors of the land
showing up whether they've been
deforested and or what's growing there
so that gives policing a better chance
yes he does and there are people who do
track these industrial trawlers around
the world and they they know from their
transponders their exact Roots they know
from the patterns that they create uh
with the with these transponders whether
they're fishing or they're just moving
from one area to another the worry
though is that still these ships can
turn these transponders off and go into
dark mode so they can't be seen but of
course when they flick them back on
there are clear questions to be asked
well why did you turn that off Captain
what were you hiding um is this just
about there overseas is it relevant to
Britain indeed is there anyone from our
own government going biodiversity is a
global issue of course many people think
about the Amazon and all the amazing
creatures that live then it's true that
we've probably only identified half of
the plants and animals there and that's
the worry that we could lose them
without even knowing they're there but
biodiversity is a global this issue if
you look at the UK we are one of the
most nature depleted countries on the
planet and the reason is that 70 percent
of our land area is farmland and most of
that Farmland is industrially farmed so
there is not much Variety in what you'll
find within a crop and that is a problem
for the insects and the birds that are
trying to thrive just to that point are
we sending anyone from the government so
we are sending the environment Minister
and also Tony Juniper from Natural
England is going but it's not prime
ministerial level so you're not going to
see world leaders there as we did with
the the climate Summit in Egypt just a
few weeks ago and going back to the UK
briefly I mean we're in a farm now or
what was a farm once was once was food
no more
um but there are issues here on this so
if we have more nature which they've got
here then where is our food going to
come from is that going to deplete
nature elsewhere that is always the
tension and you'll speak to many farmers
who say you have to grow food it is all
about food security these days
particularly with the war in Ukraine and
so on so would food prices are going up
because there isn't enough of it
but there are others who say well if you
take out the 20 of the least productive
farmland and you give it back to Nature
that in fact your food output only goes
down by three percent
we've come into the studio now so we can
hook up with other parts of the world we
will be back outside later to examine
the pros and cons of rewilding here in
the UK but first let's travel 6 000
miles to the mountains of Peru where one
man has been made a United Nations
environment program champion of the
Earth for his work dedicated to the
conservation of endangered species and
ecosystems in the Andes
foreign
is the heritage
we must to take care
biodiversity in all the countries
everything is becoming more and more in
a big threat
[Music]
many species are starting to appear like
a tretino species
[Music]
is not yet to lose one we are going to
lose all the species that are part of
the diet of this specie and also is
going to be part of the habit of this
piece
one example
[Music]
is going to disappear also more than the
150 different species of plant that is
part of the diet of the spectacle bear
we must work hard
taking action protecting the habitats
and all the areas where all these
biodiversity is still surviving
Tino from Peru so impressive who doesn't
want to be a champion of the earth and
our next guest is a pretty good
candidate too Garner's first
herpetologist in case you don't know
that someone who studies reptiles and
amphibians calab oporiborting is the
founder of herp conservation Ghana and
his passion is frogs creatures quite
vulnerable to environmental damage but
his work in Ghana shows what can be
achieved discovering several new species
and rediscovering one's thought to be
extinct and Caleb joins us now live from
the Barbary rainforest Reserve in Ghana
Caleb thanks very much tell me a little
bit about where you are immediately
around you it looks beautiful
well thank you Tom I'm talking to you
today from the Burberry Forest Reserve
also known as the Burberry butterfly
Sanctuary it's an amazing place of
rainforest that has a lot of rocks and
Butterfly as well it's one of our
important uh race stations where we
believe that we might have been
discovering quite a number of new
species uh soon tell me about some of
the the new species give me a few names
of the things the frogs that really
really excite you and you've discovered
well I'm super excited about the afia
brago puddle frog which I discovered and
described in 2018 and named after my
very dear Mother uh it's a very
fascinating frog uh there's also the
konhawa sajimasi which is one of a kind
frog species and damaged to a special
forest in Ghana called The atiwa Forest
Reserve now Caleb tell me you've been
able to actually improve the the the
plight of frogs around you around you
there and have actually changed things
for the better tell me what have you
done
foreign
I consider it a great privilege to what
we've been able to do which is basically
uh to elevate the importance of this
critically endangered species in the
eyes of all the stakeholders uh local
communities government uh to to
highlight them in terms of how unique
and important they are and to bring on
board a lot of stakeholders particularly
local communities to change the status
of this Frog We Are For example created
new forest reserves for this critically
endangered Frost and we actually have
seen a significant increase in their
population so this is really amazing and
I'm very happy and excited that I've had
the opportunity to be a part of this
success story forms so not only halting
the decline but actually increasing the
numbers of frogs there too
and suddenly that's what you've done and
I can tell you the story of the Togo
Street Frog as you may know it was
assumed to be a thing and when we
individuals known to exist in the world
our recent estimate after protecting the
habitat and stopping uh the consumption
by the local people
shows that we have about
725 individuals existing feeling in the
world this is phenomenal at home I'm
really excited about this uh progress
yeah and you don't own the land so you
have to do this in partnership with
people with with communities that seems
to be the key for you
yes
um we have had a lot of successful
Community I'm very passionate about
working with communities
um and usually you know it's a frog and
not many people want to do anything for
fraud but we use very Innovative
approaches of talking to local
communities and finally they see what we
see and and do value uh these folks some
of the methods we've used Tom is to you
know go to churches and mocks and talk
to people about the need to protect
these animals and of course what they
are various religions talk about it and
with this we've had really very massive
support for example we now protect 12
000 Acres of rainforest that we did not
buy those totally donated by the local
people including a local church so this
is really phenomenal well
congratulations on your on the recovery
of the frogs and also on your Whitley
Awards very very nice indeed to speak to
you
so far in the show we've focused on
nature loss and Recovery overseas but
this is very much a Live question here
too how should we rebuild our natural
world decimated by Decades of intensive
farming and Industry one suggestion is
rewilding simply abandoning Some Farms
to the forces and whims of nature it's
happening in 70 countries around the
world and it's catching on here even in
the home counties
you're looking at a bit of wild
bedfordshire more than three decades
since it was worked as a farm in that
time Nature has begun to take over
delivering a mixed habitat of Meadows
and scrubby trees and this is a typical
re-wilded landscape halfway through its
kind of growth to maturity as you can
see these Thorn bushes and other shrubs
are pretty hostile for humans but very
friendly for wildlife and that after all
is the point
until the early 90s this was a 150
hectare working farm growing crops to
make into food it's now the largest area
of scrubland in bedfordshire
something this man is really proud of as
soon as I saw the fight I knew we had to
save it it's just so special I know of
nowhere else on this scale in central
England that's got this wealth and
abundance of wildlife we've got huge
populations of Migrant Birds it's the
best place I've ever been to for
warblers in the spring so as you walk
every few yards there'll be a black cat
there'll be Garden warblers huge numbers
of Willow wolves and chiff 10 to 15
pairs of Nightingale up to 20 pairs of
turtle doves and we start doing more
survey work since the world I've just
got involved and in the last few weeks
we've found lots of harvest mouse nests
as well this isn't a one-off there's a
growing trend for rewilding our
landscape all the way from the highlands
of Scotland to the South Downs and it's
now being favored by government with a
policy encouraging Farmers to begin
rewilding 10 000 hectares of their land
in just two years but where does this
leave food production food was once
grown here we need food does it trouble
you that there's now no food coming from
here on this particular site I can live
with that as I say it wasn't very
productive and most of what was grown
was probably used as animal feed anyway
and over the next two or three years I
suspect we'll be reintroducing livestock
to the system that'll be good for the
habitats good for the Wildlife but will
also be a form of food production this
is a really special place and there will
always be small areas that are really
special wildlife habitats that are
devoted to Wildlife but in the wider
Farmland we need Wildlife Farmers need
Wildlife too so this site is going to be
a source of pollinators it's going to be
source of beneficial insects that will
improve farming next door
and it's going to be the place where
Wildlife over brims this site to
colonize the hedgerows that our
neighbors are already putting in the UK
Imports around 40 percent of its food
and there are concerns that increasing
that proportion could jeopardize our
supplies especially with the war in
Ukraine stressing the world's food
system
miles across bedfordshire Andrew marn
believes we have a duty to maintain Food
Supplies but that can be done while
increasing the number of birds and bees
so we're farming regeneratively the
soils at the heart of what we do that's
first and foremost a lot of our decision
making so we're growing beans wheat
barley and oats are our main crops and
then we've got quite a large Countryside
stewardship scheme trying to encourage
Wildlife really Andrew is an arable
farmer but his methods are focused on
improving soil health and he's giving
some of his worst land Back To Nature
our yields haven't dropped we're still
as productive now under our sort of
regen system as we were prior to when we
were plowing cultivating I think this is
really fascinating you're saying you
haven't seen a yield drop here yeah
we've still got the same we're still
producing the same tons of wheat per
hectare that we were previously but with
a lot less cost and a lot less impact on
the environment so when it comes to food
versus nature on our land is it either
or no absolutely farming in nature can
definitely go hand in hand I think we're
proving it here we've got some great
habitat some food for over winter food
on less productive parts of the land and
we're still producing plenty of food on
the more productive areas of the farm
win-win absolutely
another win-win is that managing land
for Nature's benefit also helps slow
climate change Andrews says his farming
practices lock carbon in the soil
meanwhile back where the scrubland rules
it's site like Strawberry Hill that's
doing Britain's bit for carbon storage
in a cheap cost-effective way compared
with most other ways of storing carbon
that will allow us to carry on farming
productively in the land in between
for centuries our civilization and
economic development have come at the
expense of nature our future depends on
growing in harmony with it
time now to answer a couple of the
questions you've been sending in and
this week it is a chewy one
Javier has asked the Earth has a history
of extreme climate Cycles so what makes
now so much more important or different
and Max asks a somewhat similar question
isn't it natural for the climate to
change wouldn't it be unnatural to try
to keep the climate constant well
instead of me answering these questions
I've enlisted the help of climate
scientist Tamsin Edwards absolutely the
climate has changed in the past and we
know that from the evidence it left
behind in things like ice cores in
sediments at the bottom of the ocean the
changes we're seeing now are much bigger
than we've seen for a very long time so
for example carbon dioxide levels are
higher than for at least two million
years the temperatures we're seeing are
getting out of the range we've been used
to through our human civilization uh
even agriculture so probably warmer than
the last six and a half thousand years
and maybe even back to before the last
ice age so over a hundred thousand years
ago
the temperatures were predicted to head
for at the moment are two and a half to
three degrees of warming again doesn't
sound like much but the last time the
planet was that warm for any length of
time was over three million years ago
when we were pretty much beginning to
craft stone tools
well as tamzin says it's fair to say
that the planet's climate has changed in
the past and now thanks to a remarkable
discovery of DNA dating back two million
years we understand more of what a
hotter world was like and how nature
could respond if global warming doesn't
slow
over in Cambridge there's excitement in
the air Professor Esco willislev has
just published groundbreaking research
that will change the way we understand
Natural History we have retrieved for
the first time DNA from an ecosystem
which is two million years old this is
from northern Greenland the very far
north of Greenland two million years ago
the temperatures were between 11 and 19
degrees warmer than today so it's kind
of similar to what we expect the Arctic
will look like in the close future due
to global warming
the DNA allows us to get a snapshot if
you want of this ecosystem that is no
longer there
when eska first suggested extracting DNA
from permafrost to understand ancient
ecosystems he was laughed at it hadn't
been done before and even he didn't know
if it would be possible for many years
we couldn't get any DNA out of these
samples whatsoever I mean it actually
got the name the the curse of the Capcom
Heaton formation in the group
after years of failure the curse was
finally lifted the team managed to get
the land's ancient DNA into a sequence
showing them what life was once like in
what's now an Arctic desert
we had been there two million years ago
right we would have been standing in in
just with our rubber boots in the ocean
right looking up on a forest diverse
forest and a mastodon and the Elephant
was running around the reindeer was
going there Goose would be flying
this is groundbreaking research it will
help us create blueprints for what
happens to ecosystems when they heat up
[Music]
excitement all around the world over
what he and his team have achieved
there's even a documentary team
following his every move
when we got the first DNA outright where
we could see there was huge damage
patterns and I just knew this week we
hit it I mean this is what you live from
as a scientist this is where you get
your energy from
making a discovery that changes the way
we look at the world we found the
Mastodon I was like oh my God no one had
ever imagined a mastodon in these
landscape is a roller coaster ride and
in the end it's like you who
are more than just showing what the
ancient world looked like this is about
helping us to map our future I believe
it can help it can make a difference
right in the world we're living in today
and I do truly believe that going back
into the past
and understanding how these genetic
adaptations how how organisms have have
handled climate change before
can give us a way where we can mitigate
these impacts right of climatic change
[Music]
that's it for the climate show this week
tune in next week for our review of the
year in climate highs lows emerging
Trends and special guests and don't
forget we'll bring you the latest every
weekday at a half past three here on Sky
News but for now goodbye
[Music]